welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and i feel like i have to
hand over my title of the spoiler man to
sony because i cannot believe what
they've done when trying to market
mobius over the weekend the studio shed
an interview for the film that was
filled with spoilers for the
post-credits scene and yeah it's a bold
strategy cotton let's see if it pays off
from now throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking down what was said
what it means for the movie and also why
they've done it because
it's absolutely bloody mental i've never
seen a company just out and out ruin the
ending of their film before even
releases but i think i might have
figured out why they've decided to do
this obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you've managed to
avoid everything and don't want it
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now make sure you hit the thumbs up
button if you enjoy the video and don't
forget to subscribe for puns that leave
you down for the count like dracula's
best mate without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into mobius
okay so before we get into what happens
in the scene i think we have to address
how brazen and sony have been with their
approach to their marvel movies if you
cast your mind back to 2019 then you
might remember that the spider-man
contract that they had with marvel
studios ran out and there was a point
where the character was no longer in the
mcu at the time it seemed like the worst
thing that could ever happen but then
2020 came along now the studios
renegotiate the contracts and though we
don't know all the ins and outs of it
there were some trade-offs sony would
allow spider-man to remain in the mcu
but they'd also have their universes
connected to it so that they could
profit off the studio's success
basically to boil it down to its
simplest terms marvel studios are you
and sonya that kid along the street that
you hated but you played with them
because they had a super nintendo do you
see what i'm saying now kevin feige
clearly knew what he was getting himself
into and because of this he kind of kept
them at ohm's length venom dropped into
the universe but he went out the door
quicker than the plans of letitia wright
becoming the next black panther and
mobius has a similar situation going on
with it in an interview with cinema plan
the director daniel espinoza has flat
out spoiled the entire ending of the
movie and because of this we can kind of
see where things could be going now we
have to address a lot the false
advertising that exists around the film
in the trailer we got shots of oz corp
the daily bugle and also a poster of
spider-man with murderer written across
the top of it the final cut of the film
doesn't contain any of these shots and
though trailers can often be misleading
i think that this was done on purpose in
order to trick people into thinking the
movie is more interesting than it is
this is the film version of click bait
and they should change the name from
mobius to more bs hey having that now
another major talking point in the
trailer is adrian toomes aka the vulture
none of the trailer scenes of the
character are in the movie and instead
our first one has the sky ripping open
much like how it didn't know a home
tombs is pulled into a jail cell in the
mobius universe much like how venom was
transported into the mcu at the end of
his last solo movie now because he
didn't commit a crime in this universe
he's led out of jail and that ends the
first scene yet completely changes the
rules of the spell but moving on and the
second post-credits scene has tombs
showing up to meet morbius in his full
vulture costume the director confirmed
that he's managed to pull his outfit
together through being resourceful and
that it's slightly different to the one
that he had on in the mcu tomb says that
he wants to form a team to get revenge
on spider-man and that ends the film so
lots of things wrong in there in terms
of the character rocks and rules that
were set up in the mcu firstly the spell
didn't allow people to jump across into
other universes at random it pulled
people into the mcu who knew peter
parker was spider-man secondly as we saw
at the end of nowhere home everyone was
sent back to their home dimension and no
one remained behind tomb seems like he's
gonna be in the mobius verse for the
foreseeable future which makes no sense
now on top of this tombs very much had
an arc in homecoming that made most
people think he didn't want to get
revenge on spider-man at the end of the
movie he was protecting his identity and
even though he didn't like him he knew
that he saved his life he seems like the
kind of person who wouldn't join the
sinister six but instead sony have
decided that he should be the person
forming it now mobius also doesn't know
spider-man so he wouldn't care about
killing him but beyond that it just
feels like they've mishandled everything
vulture is probably going to end up
going through the ark he's already been
through where he realizes spider-man's
just a kid trying to do good and he
decides to drop the vendetta now they
could spin it where tombs forgets peter
parker is spider-man and he just
remembers this superhero ruining his
life however he's now in a completely
different universe and therefore doesn't
have this relationship built up with
spider-man where it would even be the
person he hates he gets out of jail
because he's done nothing wrong in this
universe but can't drop the feud that he
has with the web head now the director
also spoiled that morbius is set in the
same universe as tom hardy's venom and
confirmed there is a spider-man but that
he couldn't say which version it is
again though we know toby has his own
venom in his universe tom is still in
the mcu which is a dimension hardy no
longer is in so process of elimination
it's andrew garfield now this is pretty
big news but i just can't trust sony to
handle things the way that they need to
be handled garfield has already had a
crap time with the studio and i wouldn't
want to see him go through it all again
it's clear that sony will do whatever
they can to make every movie connected
to the mcu and they don't care if it
ruins the universe breaks the rules or
spoils future reveals kevin feige must
be sat there doing a full 360 headshake
like reagan from the exorcist because
they have the potential to destroy all
of his hard work after hearing this no
one is going to convince me that the
venom let there be carnage post-credit
scene wasn't just banged in at the last
minute look at it they they have tom
hardy in a hotel room and then spiderman
appears on a tv screen it just screams
we quickly film this without permission
tom holland is also unmasked at penn
station which doesn't even happen in no
way home and they just don't care now a
studio spoiling a movie before releases
like this is absolutely unheard of the
news dropped at the weekend and i've
been sat here thinking for the last
couple of days over whether this has
ever happened before and i can't think
of any time where a director has ruined
their own movie before its release there
have been studios that have hinted
towards a big reveal being in a film but
the marketing of this normally happens
on the second weekend and they just
teased towards it so it seems more
interesting for those that skipped the
first viewings the review embargo hasn't
even lifted yet and it's got me saying
sony are strange so why have they done
this well i actually think it's because
sony have seen the pre-ticket sales and
they know the movie isn't gonna do well
there's also the initial reactions which
are [ __ ] on the film and though it
might end up performing okay sony seem
pretty desperate thus i think they're
doing this so that they can be like look
vultures in it from spider-man you know
him come see it it's connected the mcu
you have to see this or things won't
make sense in the future you love the
mcu this is an mcu movie it's all
connected that's the only reason i can
think that they've done this and this
strategy has worked in the past with
movies like captain marvel in which
people believed that they had to see
that in order for avengers end game to
make sense i think that sony have just
realized that no one really cares about
this film and due to all the delays
setbacks and incoming bad reviews that
they just want to get people to come and
see it because they think there's gonna
be some big mcu connections in it i
think it does the reverse in all honesty
though and now people know what's gonna
happen they're definitely not gonna
bother my guess is that most of you
watching this haven't even seen the film
yet now just checking this out because
you want to know whether it's worth
spending money to go and see it well
spoiler alert it's not you know what
happens now and i think most of you will
be put off by this rather than thinking
that you now have to cancel your weekend
plans in order to check it out after
this all the cut scenes and it just
seems like the film is one big mysterio
illusion that you don't really need to
watch people will be disappointed
knowing that the things they were
excited for aren't actually in the movie
and it just feels like a massive misfire
it's one of the dumbest things i've ever
seen and i can see why this film is
releasing on april fool's day i almost
feel like my job here is done the
spoiler man is no longer needed and
studios are just willing to ruin things
before the release i'm into minds over
whether to do a breakdown it on friday
but yeah let me know below what you
think of the whole situation we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man noway home on
the 15th of april and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and comment below with
your thoughts on what the hell is going
on we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers if you want a more
positive video about sony then check out
our breakdown on why andrew garfield's
return as the web head was so iconic we
go over the scene what happened behind
the scenes and why it means so much and
was just a brilliant moment of cinema if
not then thanks for sitting through this
video i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see on the next one take
care peace